>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Betsy Peterson: We'll get
this show on the road now.
And for those of you who have
been to other events here today,
you'll probably hear some
of the same verbiage.
So my apologies.
At any rate, hello.
I'm Betsy Peterson.
I'm the Director of the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
And I'd like to welcome everyone
here to the latest presentation
of our Benjamin Botkin
Lecture Series.
The Botkin Series allows
the American Folklife Center
to highlight the work
of leading scholars
in the disciplines of folklore.
Ethnomusicology.
Oral history.
And cultural heritage.
While also allowing us to
enhance the collections
of the American Folklife Center.
For the center in the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisition activities.
And by that I mean each lecture
is videotaped and becomes part
of the permanent collections
here at the center.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcasts
on the library's website.
Where they will be
available for viewing for,
to Internet patrons
throughout the world.
And also for future generations.
So now, if you do
have a cell phone
that is on, please turn it off.
And we will be most
appreciative.
Today I have the honor
of introducing the distinguished
ethnomusicologist Deborah Wong.
Dr. Wong, who is a professor
of music at the University
of California, Riverside, is
well-known for her research
on the musics of Thailand
and Asian America.
She began her studies at the
University of Pennsylvania.
Where she started as a
student of anthropology
and music before continuing
on to earn an MA and Ph.D.
in ethnomusicology from
the University of Michigan.
She's taught at UCR since 1996.
And has been deeply
involved with the Society
for Ethnomusicology for the
whole duration of that time.
Which is the premiere
scholarly society
for ethnomusicology
in the United States.
In addition to serving terms
on the SEM board and council,
she has also served as
coeditor of the newsletter.
And she was one of the
founders of the SEM committee
on the status of women.
And has also served as SEM's
president from 2007 to 2009.
Professor Wong is also active
in numerous other scholarly
and public sector
cultural organizations.
She has served as board
chair for the Alliance
of California Traditional Arts.
And is currently a member
of the advisory board
of Smithsonian Folkways
recordings.
Throughout all of this,
Asian-American issues
and activities have always
been a priority for Dr. Wong.
She's the author of
numerous publications.
Including the influential books
"Sounding the Center, History
and Aesthetics in
Thai Buddhist Ritual."
Which address ritual
performance and its implications
for the cultural politics of
Thai court music and dance.
And "Speak it Louder,
Asian-Americans making music."
Which focused on
music, race and identity
in Southeast Asian immigrant
communities in the Bay Area.
Including some wonderful
research
on Asian-American hip-hop.
Most recently, for
today's Botkin lecture,
Professor Wong has been studying
Japanese-American taiko drumming
since 1997.
And is a member of Satori
Daiko, the performing group
of the Taiko Center
of Los Angeles.
So we're delighted today to
have her join us and present us
with a lecture on taiko drumming
in Asian-American Los Angeles.
So please welcome Dr. Wong.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Deborah Wong:
Hello everybody.
How does this sound?
Am I about the right?
Yeah, okay.
Well, I'm looking
out at the room.
I know almost but not
quite everybody who's here.
I am related to many of
the people in the room.
Thank you Wong cousins.
Lee cousins.
And Gunning [assumed
spelling] cousins for coming.
And, of course, to be near my
valued friends and colleagues
from the American Folklife
Center this afternoon.
It means a lot to me.
Yeah, Judith, I haven't had
a chance to hug you yet.
But hello.
Yeah, you know, and Betsy.
And Nancy.
And Steve.
And, and, and, and, yeah.
And John. And Lisa, yeah.
And so, anyway, I
am going to talk
about my taiko research today.
And I did not write this out.
I'm not going to read blah,
blah, blah to you the way
that academics, you
know, are expected to do.
I'm instead just
going to talk to you.
And I'm going to use a
PowerPoint to do it with lots
of pictures and video and stuff.
Because taiko, as you
probably know, is a very loud,
a very physical, yeah,
loud and physical.
That pretty much sums up
taiko, I would say, yeah.
And just so you know, there
is another taiko player
in the room.
And that is Mark Rooney.
And I'll tell you more about
him when I get to, yeah,
he's looking around like this.
Mark Rooney who's an
amazing taiko player.
And the main taiko player
in the greater DC area.
And I'll share a slide about
him at the very end, yeah.
If you have seen
taiko, you've probably,
I'm guessing, seen this group.
Simply because they're
world famous.
No exaggeration.
And they spend about half of the
year on tour around the world.
So you, you know, generally
end up having lots of chances
to see them if you live
anywhere near a major city.
So if you've seen them,
you've probably seen
them perform something
like this piece.
Which is one of their most
well-known repertoire.
[ Drum Music ]
Now, that's a Japanese group.
I mean, and they are probably
the most famous taiko group
anywhere, any time.
And that performer
is Fujimoto Sensei.
He's very, very well-known
in the taiko community.
And if you're watching that
just cold, if you're not like,
you know, a taiko nut
the way Mark and I are.
You know, you're probably
just thinking, you know, whoa,
these guys are like in
really good shape; right?
They are totally.
They have like zero
percent fat on their bodies.
They're totally ripped,
and this is a fact.
The way they play has a kind of
intensity and commitment to it
that is not to be beat; right?
Any of us who are musicians can
respect that when we see it.
And we generally know
it when we see it.
And these guys, and there
are a few women in the group.
But they're mostly guys.
These guys play taiko, you know,
like it's an extreme sport.
And, in fact, there
are very closely,
a closely related taiko group
in Japan that is in fact known
for running a marathon,
and I mean like a marathon,
26-point whatever mile marathon.
And then playing a taiko
concert at the finish line.
You know, this kind of thing.
So that does go on
in the taiko world.
I would, I hasten to say that
it's a minority of groups
that do that kind of thing.
But Kodo and Ondekoza,
the related group,
do do that kind of thing.
That's not what I'm going
to be talking about today.
Even though all taiko
players know
about these groups from Japan.
And what they're like.
And how they think and all that.
But taiko is, as I always say,
it's both a very
old form of music.
And a very new and contemporary
one all at the same time.
And it has deep roots
in two Japanese religions,
Buddhism and Shinto.
There's much more to be
said about all these points.
But in coming to North America,
and by that I mean the
United States and Canada.
Taiko has assumed
very different kinds
of meanings than
it has in Japan.
It is still closely related
to what goes on in Japan
because taiko is huge in Japan.
Nonetheless, the meanings and
the kinds of cultural things
that taiko does for
Japanese-American
and Asian-American communities
is profoundly different
than what it does for
Japanese communities in Japan.
All right.
What it does in the U.S. is
it serves the kinds of needs
that Asian-Americans communities
have in terms of struggling
for equality, for
access to resources.
For public recognition.
For the right to
speak and to be heard.
And so on and so forth.
Taiko has come to
be, my argument is,
that taiko is central to
those kinds of struggles
for Asian-Americans
at this point.
And I'm talking about
things like this.
I'm not going to go
into it in great detail.
But in case I need
to convince anyone
that Asian-Americans
have struggles.
These are two examples.
You know, the Chinese
Exclusion Act.
Which took a long
time to discontinue.
To close. To, you
know, to, anyway.
And then the Japanese-American
internment, of course.
And that has just
been in the news again
with the supposed overturning
the Korematsu decision; right?
But in a way that
really troubles a lot
of Japanese-Americans
as a matter of fact.
So these are the
kinds of things.
And there are many other issues
that Asian-American
communities struggle with.
Have struggled with.
Continue to have
to struggle with.
Taiko is part of all of that.
And I'm going to try
and show you some ways
in which it is as I proceed.
Because not even all taiko
players want to think
of what they do as being
embedded, you know,
in these long-term
struggles for place.
For presence.
A short story on sort of
the demographics of taiko
in the U.S. and Canada.
Goes something like this.
In terms of gender, it's
about 60 percent women
and 40 percent men.
For a long time actually the
percentage of women was higher.
Maybe like 75 percent
for a long time.
And they seem to
be shifting a bit.
And I'm basing these numbers on
a census that was done in 2016.
So the numbers are
pretty current.
About 60 percent
of all performers
are Asian-American
or Asian-Canadian.
The others are primarily white.
And the numbers of Latinx
or African-American taiko
players are really small.
And I don't think that's a
coincidence or arbitrary.
I think that taiko
is serving the needs
of two ethnic groups as it were.
Racial and ethnic groups.
And a majority of taiko players
are on the young side of things.
In their 20s and 30s primarily.
Most of us play as
a leisure activity.
There are very, very few,
like, professional, full-time,
you know,
make-a-living-through-taiko kind
of people who are part
of the taiko community.
Most of us are in
community-based groups.
Some are on university campuses.
But most, the vast majority
of us are in community groups.
And you know what?
The vast, vast majority
of us are in California.
Both Southern California and
Northern California, yeah.
Now, all of this is changing
by the minute, you
know, by the day.
Taiko is in a period of
rapid expansion right now.
In fact, it's expanding
exponentially.
There are more and more taiko
groups every time I turn around;
right?
So these numbers are
going to change again.
And I wonder if at some point
California will not be the
center of the, you know, North
American taiko universe; right?
You know, I don't know.
Check back in five
years, ten years.
It's going to change.
I don't know how though.
Just to give you a sense
of what California,
Southern California taiko
community groups look like,
here's four.
And I'm going to have
fun with PowerPoint
and show you four video
clips all at the same time.
It's going to be quite a sound.
So we've got here
Pasadena in the upper left.
And, shoot, I can't remember
who's on the upper right there.
That's terrible.
This is L.A. Matsuri Taiko.
And then on the lower right is
Zendeko from Zenshuiji Temple.
So they're all in the
greater L.A. area.
Here we go.
[ Drum Music ]
So you're seeing,
these are two temples
in the greater L.A. area.
This is at the finish line
of the L.A. Marathon
a couple years ago.
Downtown L.A. And this is in
Little Tokyo on First Street.
Anybody from, any
Japanese-American
from L.A. would immediately
go, oh, that's First Street.
So, yeah, you're seeing a
lot of young players; right?
But you're also seeing
multigenerational groups.
Which is part of the magic of
taiko, in my humble opinion,
is to play with people often
from three different generations
all in the same group.
It's really cool.
[ Video Playing ]
There we go, sorry.
Here's an example of one,
what we call first generation,
arguably second generation
taiko player in North America.
This is Kenny Endo.
The most recent picture of him
is up here on the upper right.
He's been playing taiko
for just over 40 years.
He just celebrated his 40th
anniversary of taiko playing.
He's from Los Angeles.
He's Sansei, he's third
generation Japanese-American.
He started playing
taiko in the 1970s.
Which is, give or take,
when taiko took off
in the United States.
He studied in Japan.
And he's lived in Honolulu for
some decades at this point.
And is the founder and director
of the Taiko Center
of the Pacific there.
So you're seeing
photos of him here
from about three different
decades of his life.
Here he is in his first
few years of playing taiko.
And my point here, looking at
one individual for a moment,
is to say that, again,
the politics of taiko
or the political significance
of taiko may not always
be right out in front.
It may not be people, you
know, wearing political buttons
on their costumes; right?
It's probably not
going to be that.
The politics and meaning
of taiko are very deep,
run very deep and are
not always articulated.
Kenny is not going to be
the first one to tell you,
and I use his name because
he's a friend of mine.
His first name.
He's not going to tell you, oh,
yeah, I became a taiko player
through the Asian-American
movement.
That's not how he's going to
explain himself, give or take.
But, in fact, that is how he
got started back in the day.
Manzanar is one of the Japanese
American internment camps.
It's the one closest
to Los Angeles
where a lot of LAJA's got sent.
The Pilgrimage is something that
got started, in fact, in 1975.
And this was politicized
Japanese-American who's said,
we need to work on
redress and reparations.
And we need to mark the camps.
It was not a national park
at that point in time; right?
They started going just
themselves to the sites
of these former camps.
And holding, you know, meetings
and made rituals, you know,
to go with cultural and
political memory for the camps.
This is Kenny and my teacher
Reverend Tom Karye [assumed
spelling] at the first
Manzanar pilgrimage in 1975.
There's Kenny.
And look at these drums.
This drum is from Reverend
Tom's father's temple.
A Zen, Buddhist Japanese temple.
This is a wine barrel that's
been made into a taiko.
And not very well.
You can kind of, I can see that,
you know, it's kind of uneven.
It's very homemade looking.
That's Kenny, you know, 1975.
This is how he started
playing taiko.
He didn't actually have
a teacher at that point.
There was only kind of sort
of one or two other teachers
for taiko in the U.S.
at that point in time.
Here's more evidence of where
Kenny was at that point in time.
We're now up to 1978.
There he is.
This is an Asian-American
music group called Warriors
of the Rainbow led
by Nobuko Miyamoto.
Still very active.
I'm going to tell you more
about her as I go along.
Here they are in an all
Asian-American band.
You know, very much sort of
putting themselves out there
as radical Asian-Americans
at that point in time.
And there's Kenny.
With his taiko, playing
with them.
So the question is
like why taiko?
Why were these young,
mostly Sansei being drawn
to taiko rather than to
other Japanese cultural
or arts forms; right?
Because there are many.
And they were also
in the United States.
Why not sumo?
Why not Zen archery?
Why not flower arranging; right?
There's a lot of
other cultural forms
that Japanese-Americans
could have turned towards.
My argument always is
that, as a musicologist,
is that it's never arbitrary
what people turn to in terms
of performance and culture
to speak to their needs.
To address their needs.
To allow them to
explore their own needs
and vision for the world; right?
It's never arbitrary.
I think that folks
turn to taiko,
and it's not just my opinion.
People have told me this.
Because taiko is
about being heard.
It's so loud, after all.
It's about being heard.
When taiko's going on anywhere
nearby, that's, you know,
that's all you can hear.
And you can feel it
for heaven's sake.
I mean, the vibrations
literally travel.
It's about being seen.
And Asian-American visibility
is simply one of the conditions
of being Asian-American, is
that you're often
regarded as invisible.
You are not seen.
You are not heard.
You are not regarded.
And, finally, taiko
is about being strong.
Because, although you can play,
any kind of body and any kind
of ability can play taiko.
It does posit a body that has
certain kinds of strength in it.
And, in fact, to put it
the other way around.
Taiko creates a strong body
in really interesting
and important ways.
So my argument is that taiko
spoke to young Asian-Americans
at that the point in time.
And to a great extent still
does for those reasons.
For those reasons.
I mean flower arranging
is lovely.
But it doesn't serve
our needs, you know,
in quite the same ways; right?
That's my argument.
Hi. This is the founder of
taiko in the United States.
And I'm not going to
get all technical here.
But by taiko, I am referring
to a particular performance
form known in Japanese
as kumi-daiko or group taiko.
Meaning a whole bunch of
people playing a whole bunch
of different sized
taiko drums together.
Okay. Seiichi Tanaka emigrated
from Japan to the U.S. in 1968.
In 1969, he created his
own taiko school, a dojo.
And created the San
Francisco Taiko Dojo.
Which is still alive
and well and active.
And very, very important
in our scene.
He's regarded as the founder of
kumi-daiko in the United States.
In North America really.
And here he is.
You know, very, very, very
early photograph of him,
famously playing at the
San Francisco Cherry
Blossom Festival.
Now, this group, which you
should absolutely, you know,
go see them perform if
you ever have the chance.
Because they're amazing.
They have a very
particular kind of profile.
They're known thanks to
Tanaka Sensei's values
and methods for teaching.
This group is known for
being way disciplined
for supporting a certain
kind of powerful playing.
Sometimes it's called power
taiko, as a matter of fact.
The group itself is known for
being explicitly hierarchical
in its social arrangement.
And it's also known
for having a very
"traditional" male teacher
who calls the shots.
Makes the rules.
You do what he says, you know.
It's a sensei model in short.
And it works beautifully
for this group.
And Tanaka Sensei
has created many
of the second generation groups.
That is, he didn't do
it himself personally.
But many of his original
students from the 1970s and 80s,
then eventually went off and
created their own groups.
Carrying forward
some of his ideas
and playing techniques; right?
So his impact on the
North American taiko scene
is profound.
Absolutely profound.
And he did receive NEA
National Heritage Award
about 15 years ago.
Something like that, yeah.
Yeah, in recognition of that.
Some recent work being done
within the taiko community
in the United States has
suggested that any taiko player
in Canada or the United States
and possibly further away
has no more than six degrees
of separation from
Tanaka Sensei.
And you know what?
When you start talking
to people,
you find out almost right away
that it's usually
fewer than six degrees.
You know, it's often two
or three degrees; right?
Right? Mark's nodding, yeah.
Yeah. So the particular
article that I found about this,
you know, has all
these great diagrams.
Like the one you're looking at.
And taiko players love to
look at this kind of stuff.
Because it literally maps
out our social relationships
to one another; right?
And lineages, if you will.
So what I'm going to
focus on from here
on are three particular
groups and individuals.
They are, you know, just the
tip of the iceberg; right?
And I didn't choose them
because they're like, you know,
famous as much as they suggest
different ways of playing taiko.
And different kinds
of values that they,
different reasons
for playing taiko.
So I'm going to talk
about Kinnara Taiko
and then TAIKOPROJECT.
And then FandangObon at the end.
So let me start with
Kinnara Taiko.
They are known as
taiko pioneers.
And that term "pioneer," I
can't say that I'm fond of it.
Because it suggests the
kind of, you know, what?
Settler colonialism; right?
But it is the term that's used
within the North American
taiko community to suggest
that we can recognize the
founding generation, as it were.
And so along with Tanaka Sensei
say who is often regarded
as being like the only
first gen pioneer.
I would argue that Kinnara Taiko
was the other first generation
pioneer group.
They were founded like, you
know, virtually the same year
as San Francisco Taiko Dojo.
But they were located
at a Jodoshinshu
temple in Los Angeles.
Senshin Buddhist Temple.
Where I spend a lot of time.
And what they did
through Reverend Mas who's
in the back there.
Reverend Mas Kodani has
explicitly positioned taiko
playing as hogaku, as a
form of Buddhist practice.
Certainly a lot of fun to play,
but not being played
only for fun.
You know, as a form
of Buddhist devotion.
And the structure of the group,
thanks to Reverend Mas was very
explicitly nonhierarchical.
Which make it's profoundly
different
from San Francisco Taiko Dojo.
And, in fact, egalitarian
in how they acted stuff out.
How they made decisions
together.
It was consensus driven.
There were apparently hours
and hours of conversation
to make any kind of
decision together; right?
You know, this kind of thing.
So this is a great photograph
of a lot of those folks
from that first generation.
And many of them are
still around and still
at Senshin Buddhist Temple.
I want you to see
just a little slice
of them playing back in the day.
This is a documentary
that was made
in 1975 titled "Cruisin'
J-Town."
J-Town is Japan Town.
It's filmed in Little Tokyo
in L.A. And you're going
to see first Johnny Mori, who
is another noted taiko player
in L.A. You're going to
see him as a young man sort
of making his way through
the Asian-American movement.
And going to Amerasia Bookstore.
And then you're going
to see him wind
up at Senshin Buddhist Temple
playing with Kinnara Taiko.
And he's still with Kinnara.
[ Music ]
>> I look in the mirror, I'm
traditional Japanese looking.
I mean, I got slanted eyes.
The black hair; right?
So every day I look,
you know, it's Japanese.
But yet, on the other hand,
I'm Japanese-American.
I can relate more to a black
or a Chicano than I can
to a person from Japan.
So that's why, you know,
creating an Asian-American thing
that I could feel
comfortable with, you know,
I think it's pretty important.
>> Hey.
>> Hey, what's happening?
Working here in the bookstore,
it's an atmosphere where I'm
in contact with our history
here in the United States.
And it started to dawn on me
that music was another
expression
that I could possibly
use to get into as far
as an Asian-American
identity kind of thing.
[ Drum Music ]
>> Dr. Deborah Wong:
Historic footage, this.
And it's filmed at
Senshin Buddhist Temple.
And guess what?
Tomorrow is their
annual Obon Festival.
And I'm going to fly
home tomorrow and land
at Ontario Airport and then
drive straight to Senshin, yeah.
I love their Obon ritual.
And the last thing that
happens at the Senshin Obon is
that Kinnara always plays.
It's about nine or ten
o'clock at night at that point.
And they play, as you know,
horaku or hogaku, as
Buddhists worship.
I mean, it looks just
like taiko you'd anywhere.
But it's purpose is different.
So that's one group.
And they're still
very much around.
They're, many of
them are now older.
But they've brought
in younger members.
The group continues.
Its spirit, its philosophy,
its values remain very
securely in place.
So they're there.
They're part of the scene.
They're respected.
They're known.
They're recognized.
They're pioneers.
I want to turn to
the second group now.
And that's TAIKOPROJECT.
And that is how they call
themselves, TAIKOPROJECT.
One word. All capital letters.
Okay. And this is one could say
a third generation taiko group.
And it's mostly,
when they started,
over 10 years 15 years
ago, they were in fact all
in their 20s at that point.
And this is part of what's going
on with taiko more
broadly; right?
Is that taiko is
growing, is expanding.
There's literally more
groups, more taiko players.
More infrastructure
than there once was.
And what usually happens
when you have more people
doing things, right,
is that they begin to divide
off into different scenes.
Different kinds of ways
of doing things; right?
So literally the
taiko community,
if we can still call it that,
is now more and more diverse
in terms of how they do things.
And who they do things with.
And so like regional taiko
is now more of a thing
than it once was, for instance.
But these, the scene is
still connected in very,
very interesting ways.
This is all about the
rising generation.
Any tradition faces this.
What happens when new
generations become part
of that tradition?
It all depends; right?
Sometimes things are very
carefully kept the same,
whatever that might mean.
But often it means that
things begin to change.
Again, responding to the
conditions of the time,
of the moment, of the place.
So the rising generation
of taiko players,
and I think actually there's
two rising generations
at this point.
Many of them were trained
in collegiate groups.
Taiko clubs on university
and college campuses.
Some of them also came up
through community groups.
Some of them are doing both,
which is very interesting.
A number of these folks are
very aware of taiko history.
Others are not at all.
If they just joined taiko as
a club on campus, you know,
it's they're having
a great time.
They're learning a lot,
but history is the
least of it; right?
Many of these groups, because
these are young players,
they're in their teens and 20s.
They have like these
amazing bodies; right?
And, you know, they're
brains are just like firing.
And they create these
pieces that are
like incredibly complicated
with lots of different sections.
And, you know, complex meters.
And, you know, all kinds
of stuff like this.
And some of them very much want
to become professional
taiko players at this point.
Here's some lovely
photos of some
of the leaders now
actually pushing 40.
Some of the first rising gen.
Michelle Fuji up on the right.
Bryan Yamami, who
founded TAIKOPROJECT.
And these are members
of the On Ensemble.
Maz Baba. Kris Bergstrom.
Shoji Kameda.
This is TAIKOPROJECT, a photo
that's now a decade old taken
in Little Tokyo.
Actually a couple blocks away.
But, you know, this absolutely,
this like sums up the spirit
of TAIKOPROJECT, you know.
They're all in their 20s pretty
much at that point in time
with all the energy
and enthusiasm; right?
A lot of their pictures are
of them leaping into
the air; right?
This kind of thing.
It's a great photo.
And I might say that Bryan's
also been very careful
to have really professional
standards brought to everything
that TAIKOPROJECT does.
Including PR.
So TAIKOPROJECT, it's a group
of third gen taiko players.
Yeah, they're all
about energy and kind
of a playfulness as well.
Which is not typical of like
Japanese type of groups,
if one can generalize.
They're often, you
know, like smiling.
And, you know, there's laughter
and jokes built into
their pieces.
They are very aware of
their Japanese roots.
But they are also
unapologetically
and openly American
in what they're up to.
And the membership
of TAIKOPROJECT is almost
entirely Asian-American.
Not just Japanese-American,
but also, you know, Chinese.
Korean. Filipino.
You know, different
Asian-Americans.
There are a few non-Asian
Americans, but not many.
Another photo of them.
With Bryan Yamami and the
founder in the middle there.
And you need to see them play.
This is one of their
very well-known pieces.
And, again, in sort
of counterpoint
to Japanese taiko values,
Shoji Kameda, then a member
of TAIKOPROJECT, wrote
this piece explicitly
as an open-source piece.
Open to any taiko group to play.
No ownership.
Not tied just to TAIKOPROJECT.
But a piece that he
framed as being a gift
to the taiko community.
An omiyage.
It means gift.
Actually, it means a kind
of gift that you bring back
when you've been
traveling somewhere.
And you get little souvenirs
to bring home and give
to your friends and family.
That's what an omiyage is, yeah.
This is part of a
much longer piece.
[ Drum Music ]
In, wearing the orange shirt
in the center there,
that's Yuta Kato.
An amazing performer.
Now has risen to a real
position of leadership
in the greater North
American taiko community.
And you can hear at one point
some of the other players
on stage yell out Yuta.
You know, as he took
off on his solo; right?
One of the other things
that TAIKOPROJECT has done very
adroitly is to insert themselves
into the greater L.A.
entertainment industry.
We are after all in L.A.
; right? It's about La-La Land.
It's about, you know,
all the opportunities
that the film industry,
the entertainment
industry generally offers.
And Bryan Yamami, the director
and founder of TAIKOPROJECT
in very well-known ways
has made TAIKOPROJECT,
has put them out there.
And you find them in a
number of commercials.
You see them playing at
industry conferences.
You know, and they also play
in community settings,
to be very clear.
They're playing in a
lot of different places.
But they're also cultivating
this kind of thing.
2005, they played in this
one minute commercial
for the Mitsubishi Eclipse.
[ Drum Music ]
>> Introducing the all new
2006 Mitsubishi Eclipse.
Available six speed,
263 horse, MIVEC V6.
>> Dr. Deborah Wong:
You get the idea.
I have very mixed feelings
about this commercial.
I think it's really slick.
It's really you know,
it's well done.
But it also feeds directly into
like really tired ideas about,
you know, Orientalist
dragon lady, you know,
Asian babe in a red dress
kind of stuff, you know.
And, or I should, it
wouldn't even be Asian; right?
It would be Oriental
babe in a red dress.
And there's more to be
said about this commercial.
I mean, one is that the
folks who are looking
for taiko players were
making the commercial.
And they went out into
the greater L.A. area.
Lots of taiko groups; right?
And they auditioned a whole
lot of different taiko players
for this commercial
back in the day.
They also auditioned
members of my group.
And they looked at us,
and we were a bunch of at
that point sort of
middle-aged, you know,
not necessarily beautiful
looking people
who played taiko very well.
But they looked at us and were
like, okay, thanks very much.
And then they went onto to the
TAIKOPROJECT and said, oh, wow,
look at these young
women; right?
You know, and so you end
up with this commercial.
Which I think shows
off the playing ability
of at least the young
women in TAIKOPROJECT.
But it feeds into other
kinds of cultural tropes
that I am tired of
seeing; right?
As I said, in 2016,
a census was done.
A voluntary census
of taiko players.
And we learned at that
point that a majority
of taiko players
are, in fact, women.
And Asian-American
women at that.
And a number of us
had anecdotally
and just impressionistically
known that for a long time.
But the numbers were confirmed
at this point in time.
And we also began to realize
that our own way of thinking
and talking about
who plays taiko
and why was becoming
complicated.
And has been actually
for a while.
One is the matter,
is taiko Japanese?
Some groups always say,
well, this is Japanese taiko.
Even if all of them are
from Chicago, you know.
Is taiko really a
Japanese-American form?
Is it now more broadly
Asian-American.
Which would be my argument.
Or is it, in fact, for
everyone, you know?
And that's where things
get dicy, in my opinion.
I think any music at some
level could be argued
as being for everyone.
You know, but what does it
mean when suddenly any kind
of music becomes
ownable by anyone?
Could be participated
in by anyone?
What does that mean?
You know, what happens
with global spread
of certain traditions?
What does it mean when every
jazz band has a didgeridoo
in the middle?
You know, this kind of thing.
So I have questions about what
it means to be for everyone.
And that might be
where taiko's going.
But, for instance,
in the Midwest these are
two different taiko groups
in Indiana and Minneapolis.
What does it mean when
this becomes the face
of taiko players?
And let me be very clear,
I'm not saying white
people shouldn't play taiko.
I am not saying that.
I'm not thinking it either.
But I am saying that
race and gender
and community location is
significant in any form
of performance in terms of what
are the stories being told?
What is the narrative
being served?
And by whom?
For whom? So taiko is changing.
It's changing fast.
And this is TAIKOPROJECT.
It remains, you know, 90
percent Asian-American
in it's personnel.
And very much connected to the
Japanese-American community.
Let me turn to my final
example, FandangObon.
And this is a form, a project.
It's really a project that is
about connecting two very
specific communities in L.A.,
in the greater L.A. area.
It's about activism.
It has everything to do
with the fact that more
than once interethnic
violence and tension
between different
neighborhoods and communities
in L.A. burst open
in very violent ways.
Very controversial ways.
And so the L.A. uprising
or riots
of 1992 was not the first
time that this happened.
So I'm just offering
you a little reminder
that this is part of the
landscape of Los Angeles
and has been for a long time.
So FandangObon is primarily
these three amazing thinker,
performers, activists.
I cannot get enough time
with these three people.
On the left we have
Quetzal Flores.
We have Martha Gonzales.
And the two of them with some
other folks make up the band,
Quetzal, which is all
it's in Chicago a lot.
And then Nobuko Miyamoto
on the right here.
The three of them
are close friends.
And they created the FandangObon
project together five years ago.
Fandango is central to
a very specific area
of Mexico of the Veracruz area.
Fandango, it's a very
explicitly participatory form
of performance and
community gathering.
Obon is the Japanese
and Japanese-American,
it's now a summer festival.
Originally a time when, part
of the Japanese Buddhists
recognition of ancestors.
Some say a time when the souls
of the departed come
back and visit us.
So both of these forms,
Fandango and Obon are dynamic.
Alive. Well.
Not endangered in their
communities; right?
These are dynamic traditions.
They're flourishing even.
Both of them have
these similarities
in their emphasis
on participation.
That you don't need to be like
a professional or trained person
to participate in them.
They're meant for
anybody to be part of.
They're focused on community.
And both of them are deeply
informed by the politics
in the United States
of the 1960s and 70s.
When like the Chicano
movement got going.
The Asian-American
This is part of both
scenes as well.
So a glimpse of Obon in L.A.
This is higashi [phonetic]
with taiko in the middle.
The dances are participated
in by hundreds
and hundreds of people.
This is the time of year
where every weekend a different
temple is hosting Obon.
And people go from one temple to
another over the entire summer.
So hundreds of people.
Some temples there's over 1,000
people dancing altogether.
Fandango. This photograph is
from L.A. I think the
next one is from Seattle.
But the Fandango scene,
son jarocho is very
lively right now.
And you can see how
people just sort
of gather into a loose circle.
And there's dancing
going on in the middle.
And jaranas playing all around
the outside of the circle.
Fandango. Yeah, this is Cesar
Castro, who does live this LA.
So too much text.
But the point being that
there's a lot of similarities
between these two forms.
Both are all about
participation.
They're not about
professional trained people.
Both of them are open-ended and
can go on for quite a while.
It's not like, you know, they do
say like, we're going to start
at 7:00 and end around
9:00 kind of thing.
But they could go on as long
as you want them to go on.
They are noncompetitive
in their spirit.
Doesn't matter whether
you're a good dancer
or a completely clueless dancer.
You just get out
there, and you do it.
And nobody cares.
Everybody admires good
dancing when they see it.
But you don't have to
be good to be part.
Both of them are
transnational in the ways
that performers are
connected to people
in the countries of origin.
And there's often
movement, continuous,
between the two places.
The two homelands.
One emerged at part
of the Chicanx movement
in the United States.
Fandango is very old.
But in the United States it was
part of the Chicano movement.
Obon's a little different
in that it's been part
of JA community for over
a century at this point.
And was revived after
World War Two.
And you need to see FandangObon
before I tell you more about it.
It was on the mall two years
ago as part of the festival,
the Smithsonian's
festival, Folklife Festival.
Mark and I were part
of, for a week we were
on the mall playing this
a couple times a day.
It was a great experience.
I still, like had
such a great time.
And it was so meaningful
for all of us.
But this video is from a
few years before we all came
to Washington.
The first year of the project.
[ Music ]
Sorry, that was pretty loud.
But what's going on here
is that the East L.A.,
traditionally Mexican-American,
Chicanx neighborhood
and Little Tokyo, right
across the L.A. River
from East L.A. This
project brought those two
neighborhoods together.
Very intentionally; right?
This was a result of months and
months and months of planning
and discussion and meetings.
Martha and Quetzal
being deeply embedded
in the East L.A.
Chicanx community.
Nobuko and others and Reverend
Mas here being, you know,
key figures in Little Tokyo.
So they took the elements of
both of those traditions, right,
and they put them together.
Fandango and Bon Odori.
This re-embeds taiko in the kind
of, you know, big ritual dance
and more tradition that it
actually is most profoundly
embedded in.
It took the dance
steps from Bon Odori
and injected moves
from Fandango.
Some of the foot movements.
Other, you know, this is
Guacamaya is from Fandango.
It's a very careful attempt
from culture barriers
to create a new form.
Not meant to be like fusion
or anything like that.
But meant to represent
qualities of both traditions.
And meant to be carried forward.
We're now in the fifth
year of FandangObon.
It is being performed
at many different Obon
in the greater L.A. area
this summer, as it has been
for the past four years.
So this is the amazing
circle of performers
that created the
project together.
And as Reverend Mas says,
this shouldn't be a fusion.
Because a lot of
intercultural talk is often
at that level, you know.
It's fusion.
It's like, you know,
fusion cuisine, you know.
Like where you throw some
soy sauce and some nam pla
and some lime and some adobo.
And, you know, we
put it all together.
And it's great, you know.
And that's kind of the extent
of the thinking; right?
Reverend Mas is like,
no, it's not fusion.
It's not fusion.
It's putting different elements
together, and it's doing it
in a very thoughtful
and intentional way.
It's creating a conversation.
A conversation, yeah.
This is the mission.
They've had to apply
for grants to get some
of this off of the ground.
You often have to have
a mission statement
when you apply for
grants, you know.
So they had chances where
they were able to sort
or articulate what
they were up to.
And these are the bottom lines
for the FandangObon project.
Kind of musical dialogue.
Open cultural borders.
It's not about trying to
make those borders dissolve
or go away.
Because that's magical thinking.
It's about trying
to open the borders,
sometimes only temporarily,
between diverse Angeleno
communities.
Can ritual circle dance,
these are both ritual
traditions; right?
Can ritual circle dance help us
to imagine a new
vision for Los Angeles?
And I would argue yes.
I believe it has been happening
through this project
among other ways.
And here we are all on the
mall two years ago in our tent.
Yeah, and there's
Mark Rooney right
in the middle, playing taiko.
Yeah, I love this photo, yeah.
So let me wrap this up.
Yeah. Taiko in L.A. It
could not be more dynamic.
More vital.
More alive.
More rooted in community.
I'm speaking to my
values at this point.
Because I'm a certain
generation.
I'm an ethnomusicologist.
I'm an Asian-American.
I bring certain hopes.
I bring certain hopes
to all kinds
of different cultural forms.
And taiko is definitely
one of them.
So the community base for taiko
in L.A. remains very strong.
This is Sogenji Buddhist Temple.
My home temple.
There's my teacher Reverend
Tom [phonetic], playing.
This is First Street.
Yeah, playing at the end
of the Nisei Week Festival.
This is Nobuko, playing
with some former members
of Warriors of the Rainbow.
You saw their photo back at the
beginning of the presentation.
With taiko right in
the middle of the mix.
Taiko is alive.
And this is a mural in Little
Tokyo right around the corner
from the, kind of
across the street
from the Japanese-American
National Museum.
A community mural that was
made about 20 years ago
about Little Tokyo, and it's
significance for JA community.
And do you see what's over
in the corner of the mural?
Yeah. Those are members
of Kinnara actually.
If you want to know
more about taiko,
I'm happy to say there's now
three books out in English,
in the English language.
"Taiko Boom" is more about,
well, it is about taiko
in Japan, not in North America.
This book, the middle one "The
Way of Taiko" was written by one
of Tanaka Sensei's students.
So it's very much
about a view of taiko
through San Francisco
Taiko Dojo values.
And this book "Drumming
Asian America" just came
out by Angie Ahlgren.
And it's fantastic.
And she looks mostly at taiko
in the Midwest, not California.
But the Midwest, in the
greater Minneapolis area.
And the kinds of race politics
that come into play there.
So, of course, at this point
you're sitting there thinking,
but I'm in DC.
And I'm not in California.
I'm in California.
You're not in California.
And where can I see taiko?
Well, I'm happy to say that
there is more than one place.
But the main place, to
my biassed state of mind,
is Mark Rooney, who has been
here for a few years now.
And very quickly has
established classes.
Performances.
He's based in College
Park, Tacoma Park.
There's his web page if
you want to take a look.
He's an amazing performer.
Amazing musician.
A great teacher.
I've had lots of contacts
with Mark over the years.
I encourage you, he
can tell you more.
He said, you have to run away
at this point pretty quickly.
But you might want to grab
him if you're at all curious.
Because he's right
here, after all.
And I just want to say thank
you to all of the people
who made it possible for me
to know more about taiko.
To learn more.
To be able to think
deeply about it with them.
And to allow me to be here
today to tell you about it.
And to share my obvious
passion for this topic.
Thank you for listening.
[ Applause ]
What is your tradition
at this point?
Do we all just sort
of part ways or?
>> Questions, anybody
has questions?
>> Dr. Deborah Wong: Okay.
>> Thanks, Deb.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Where are the drums made?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, just.
>> Dr. Deborah Wong:
I was hoping
to come closer to you all.
But, yeah.
Where are the drums made?
That is a very interesting
matter, as a matter of fact.
Originally, in the 70s there
was a whole North American new
tradition of making taiko
out of wine barrels.
Literally buying
them from wineries.
Disassembling them.
Extensive techniques went into
how to put them back together
into really functioning taiko.
And we all knew the
different places
where you could buy cow hide.
Cow hide. You know,
this kind of thing.
And many collegiate groups,
many community groups continued
to learn how to do that.
And it's not only considered to
be important cultural knowledge
to know how to make a taiko.
But to do it communally,
collectively together,
in short, you know.
To get covered with
sawdust and all that stuff
that goes along with it; right?
This is beginning to change.
Lots of folks still
make their own drums.
But five years ago one
of the major Japanese
taiko-making companies
and families, Asano opens their
first North American store.
And it's in the greater
L.A. area.
It's in Torrance.
Yeah, and they've
created this amazing venue
where they teach classes.
They have a showroom
where you can drop a lot
of money on beautiful stuff.
And more and more groups are
buying their drums from Asano.
I'm curious about
how this is going
to change the scene, you know.
And some of those drums are made
out of literally a
single piece of wood.
You know, it's very different
from the wine barrel technique.
You know, is this hauling us
back to a certain sort of,
you know, Japanese-centered
way of doing things?
It remains to be seen.
Their stuff is expensive.
So not everybody's going
to be able to buy them.
So the drums are from
both here and there.
Great question.
>> Yeah, what are the difference
between the Chinese drums
[inaudible], Chinese drums
and the taiko you're
talking about?
Because I know in
China they have,
different regions
have different type
of drum performance sort of.
Did you see any relationship
between the two?
>> Dr. Deborah Wong: The
simplest answer is like, no.
You know, but I think one
could point to, more broadly
to an East Asian arc of
percussion where some
of the manufactured
techniques are similar.
But the context are
pretty different.
I do think, for what it's worth,
that the global phenomenon
of taiko becoming popular
beyond Japan has led to, like,
some Chinese drum
groups that are drawing
from ideas about Japanese taiko.
And, you know, now
they're playing, you know,
like Lion Dance type
Chinese drumming.
But with a lot of kind of
taiko moves and rhythms put in.
It's very, very interesting.
I mean, but the deeper
answer is that, no,
they're not directly related.
And, two, they're part of a
broader East Asian emphasis
on certain kinds of
percussion for ritual.
For ritual.
>> Oh, yeah.
I think you're talking about
more from U.S. point of view.
But have you ever done
any research in China?
Because I know it's
for thousands
of years they have
this drum performance.
I'm sure in.
>> Dr. Deborah Wong:
This is true.
>> In history is, you know, in
history there must be some kind
of a learning from each other.
Or, you know, it might
be the other way around.
But I'm just throw a point here.
But, you know, it's interesting
I just want to make a comment.
Because yesterday I
went to Smithsonian.
And the new director for
the national art museum,
National Museum for
African Art, Gus Hayford.
He also mentioned something
about the African drum.
And the, he brought
up another perspective
of this drum performance in
the history that is more like,
expressed quantifiable pain.
And also express hope, you know,
to manifest their sufferings.
And also their hope for
more equality in history.
I guess to this type
of performance more
like entertainment.
I'm just making comment,
you know.
He said that for African drum,
it's more like, you know,
almost like a code
for revolution.
But in certain type of the
period during the history,
that it was not allowed
for African-American.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Dr. Deborah Wong: Oh, for
slaves in the United States.
>> People to perform,
to play drums.
Because it's so inspiring,
I guess.
You know, it's like a
[inaudible] for revolution.
That's what he commented.
I'm just trying to make some
kind of connection here.
>> Dr. Deborah Wong: Well,
you just said a whole bunch
of different things, and
they're all very interesting.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah. Let me put it this way.
You know, if you look at sort
of music in a global context,
you know, every place
has its own kinds
of musical instruments.
And that's like really
interesting to those of us
who look at world music.
It's very striking that
drums are found everywhere.
And that, by that I mean, you
know, a body with some sort
of membrane stretched
over the end.
Which is then struck; right?
That's what I mean by a drum.
Again, in East Asia there are
very old traditions of drumming.
Many of them connected
directly to Buddhism
and in Japan's case
Shinto as well.
And to original religions,
you know.
Indigenous religions,
if you will.
Are they directly connected?
I'm just going to doggedly
say, no, they're not.
Because, in fact, there's
one way of sort of looking
at music around the world.
Which is to say, everything
started in one place
and then went to
some place else.
And there's a long tradition
of saying, in east Asia,
that stuff started in China, and
it moved out from there; right?
And in some cases it's true.
In other cases it
ends op sort of wiping
out indigenous traditions
and practices.
Or at least attention to
things that do originate
in places outside China.
So, I mean, these are
complicated questions.
And to bring it full circle back
to where you ended with slaves.
You know, in the African slave
trade and diaspora, yeah,
percussion was regarded by slave
owners as inherently dangerous.
Because it allowed
slaves to continue
to practice their own religions.
And points of view.
And ways of coming
together communally.
And that was a problem
for slave owners.
Yeah. Yeah.
Hi.
>> Hi, thanks so much.
It was really fun to hear
about your work as usual.
And it's a real treat
with all the stuff
with the festival going on.
All of these events around
world performance traditions are
happening in town.
I was curious, I
missed the beginning.
So if there was something
you provided as context
that you've already
covered here.
But I'm picking up a little
bit on the way you were talking
about the different groups
that you're discussing.
And sort of, you know,
generations of musicians.
Things are changing over time.
And some of the things that
I've researched in the Midwest
and sort of European ethnic
revivals and things you,
people sometimes
talk about patterns
between different
generations, you know.
Different sort of trends
toward assimilation.
Wanting to recognize sort of
cultural traditions versus not.
And it sounds like there's a lot
of different things
going on here.
So, you know, even
in the 60s and 70s,
it seems like there were
very divergent philosophies
about what this performance
could mean.
So I'm just curious, since you
were talking about generations.
If you're kind of
seeing patterns as sort
of things develop over time?
>> Dr. Deborah Wong: Just as you
can imagine, I see both patterns
and sustained ideas and values.
But I also see a lot of
change at the same time, yeah.
You know, not surprisingly;
right?
Both are going on, yeah.
I do think we're
at a tipping point
in the greater taiko scene.
I do think that the emphasis
on Japanese-American
community is going to begin
to fall away, you know.
And, you know, I'm trying
to be ready for that
and to accept it
when it happens.
For me personally, it still
is the most meaningful kind
of taiko.
But clearly that's not
the case for many people.
So that's a change.
So, you know, what you're
saying points to the ways
in which heritage, culture
in general sort of plays
out all of those things.
Often at once; right?
Sometimes in contradictory ways.
You know, and I know
you've seen some of that
in your own research
on the Midwest; right?
Yeah, yeah.
So those are the questions.
Yeah.
>> I want to thank Professor
Wong again for coming
for a wonderful lecture today.
Let's give her another
round of applause, please.
[ Applause ]
And thank you all for coming.
And please join us again next
Tuesday at 12 o'clock in this,
in the main auditorium
for a wonderful concert
of Armenian music by Tut.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Armenian, yes.
So please come back then.
And thank you again for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.